Mon père avait une politique
particulière :
il ne me donnait pas
d’argent de poche ;
il refusait de m’offrir
des CD de musique,
des vêtements
— des jeux vidéos
c’était même pas la peine de
demander.
En revanche,
pour les livres,
c’était budget
ILLIMITÉ.
Je pouvais lui demander
le livre que je voulais,
même plusieurs livres :
peu importe le prix,
il payait sans discuter.
Bon,
en même temps
il n’était pas fou :
il savait bien
que je n’allais pas le ruiner
avec des livres de poche…
Je me souviens aussi
que s’il me trouvait devant la télévision,
ou l’ordinateur,
il venait se placer devant moi,
il me fixait
jusqu’à ce que je réagisse,
et il me disait :
« LIS, LIS ! »
T’avais pas complètement raison,
Papa.
« Lire, c’est mal »
« Mais comment
vous pouvez dire ça !! »
Du calme
du calme !
Je ne vais pas essayer de vous convaincre
de passer vos journées
sur Netflix
ou à jouer à des jeux vidéos.
Ce que je vais faire,
c’est critiquer la lecture
TELLE QUE
l’immense majorité des gens
la pratiquent
— et telle que je la pratiquais
MOI-MÊME
jusqu’à il y a encore quelques années,
je dirais cinq six ans.
Et vous me voyez peut-être venir :
vous dire
que nous ne devons pas lire
comme nous lisons,
ça sera le moyen de comprendre
ce qu’est la BONNE
manière de lire,
celle qui nous permet
de tirer les IMMENSES
bénéfices de la lecture.
Oui mais c’est quoi,
ces IMMENSES
bénéfices ?
Bonne question.
J’y réponds,
je vous explique tout
dans les prochaines minutes.
Écoutez-moi attentivement
JUSQU’AU BOUT
et non seulement vous connaîtrez
la vérité sur la lecture,
mais en plus vous saurez quoi faire
CONCRÈTEMENT
pour tirer un immense bénéfice
de vos lectures.
L’être humain a besoin
de manger pour vivre
PARAÎT-IL
À cet égard,
nous pouvons dire
qu’il est bon de manger,
puisque si nous cessons
de nous alimenter,
nous en mourrons.
Cesser de s’alimenter,
c’était d’ailleurs une méthode
pour se suicider,
dans l’Antiquité
— une légende raconte que Pythagore
aurait mis fin à ses jours
comme ça.
Donc il faut manger pour vivre,
d’accord.
Mais cela signifie-t-il
qu’il faut manger
N’IMPORTE QUOI ?
Bien sûr que non.
L’évolution de l’être humain
a mis en évidence,
sur la très longue durée,
ce qui est COMESTIBLE,
c’est-à-dire ce qui peut
lui servir d’aliment.
Mais même parmi ce qui est comestible,
nous n’avons pas intérêt
à nous nourrir
de N’IMPORTE QUOI.
Oui,
nous avons besoin de nous nourrir,
mais si vous prenez
vos trois repas quotidiens
chez MacDonalds…
ça va mal se terminer.
C’est donc simple :
certains aliments sont bons pour la santé,
d’autres moins.
Eh bien c’est la même chose
pour la lecture :
certains livres
NE SONT PAS
un bon aliment
pour votre esprit.
Je peux prendre un exemple
extrême :
est-il bon de lire
de la propagande nazie ?
À part si vous êtes
un historien professionnel
qui TRAVAILLE
sur la propagande nazie,
la réponse est NON.
Mais il y a plein de livres
que l’on peut comparer
à de la malbouffe,
qui sont un peu l’équivalent de Netflix,
mais au format écrit.
C’est par exemple le cas
de ce qu’on appelle
« la littérature de gare »,
c’est-à-dire les livres superficiels
qu’on peut lire facilement
et rapidement
en attendant son train.
On peut comparer ces livres,
comme la plupart des séries Netflix,
à de la malbouffe,
parce que leur lecture
est du pur divertissement
— on lit pour passer le temps.
Alors que le bénéfice attendu
de la lecture,
ce qui est implicite
dans les encouragements des parents
à leurs enfants,
c’est que la lecture
nous rend plus intelligents :